Trascrizione: Giulia Dani
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Non è una favola,
non è una seduta da uno psicoterapeuta,
non è una cavalcata a briglie sciolte
sulle spiagge italiane:
è semplicemente un racconto,
forse un po' onirico,
da questo avvio forse un po' presuntuoso;
ma su questo ci tornerò
tra poco, e vi spiegherò il perché.
Un percorso sognato, immaginato,
fin da quando ero bambina,
con un microfono in mano.
Ero sempre la prima a salire:
mi facevano sempre salire
per prima, sul palcoscenico,
all'asilo e alle scuole elementari.
Una bambina che poi è diventata
ragazza, donna, professionista
e che ha intrapreso il suo
percorso di crescita professionale.
Non so se a voi sta a giudicare,
non so se questo è il mio percorso,
se alla fine di questo speech
lo condividerete, vi sarà piaciuto -
potevo far meglio,
potevo fare di più: non lo so.
A me piace pensare
che "The best is yet to come":
il meglio deve ancora venire.
Ma torniamo all'incipit,
o meglio alla "lead".
La lead è l'apertura
di un'edizione del telegiornale,
il primo servizio
che va in onda dopo la sigla.
Beh, la mia sigla stasera
l'avrete riconosciuta,
perché è un'aria famosissima:
"Nessun dorma", con la voce
straordinaria di Pavarotti,
da "La Turandot" di Puccini;
ma l'ho scelta perché, in questo
periodo, è un po' anche la mia sveglia,
è la mia suoneria
che mi butta giù dal letto
ogni mattina alle quattro e trenta
e mi dà la carica giusta
per arrivare negli studi della Rai,
Radiotelevisione Italiana, a Saxa Rubra,
e prepararmi ogni mattina
per condurre la trasmissione "Unomattina".
Unomattina è una trasmissione
che va in onda da veramente
tantissimi anni, da 35 anni.
Io ricordo una delle primissime puntate:
ero una ragazzina, nel 1986,
erano i giorni durante
le vacanze di Natale.
E quella sigla - perché la sigla
è rimasta sempre la stessa - che sentivo,
mai avrei immaginato
che un giorno quella sigla
l'avrei sentita dall'altra parte,
cioè dallo studio e non davanti alla tv.
Vi voglio far vedere questa foto.
Eccomi.
Questa foto è stata scattata
17 ore fa, in sala trucco, stamattina;
e fortunatamente, il sabato e
la domenica "Unomattina" non va in onda.
Ecco perché stasera posso essere
qui sul palco di TEDxFermo,
e naturalmente ricordare,
in questa bellissima Villa Vitali,
i miei momenti da ragazzina,
e da bambina, in cui venivo con mia nonna.
E sì perché io sono nata a Fermo,
i miei genitori erano fermani,
i miei nonni lo stesso;
e poi sono cresciuta
a qualche chilometro da qua,
a Pedaso, sul mare.
Quando, qualche tempo fa,
l'organizzatore di TEDxFermo
mi ha telefonato
per invitarmi a essere
una speaker, stasera,
ho pensato subito:
wow, fantastico, che bello!
Ero orgogliosa e lusingata:
caspita, partecipare come speaker
a un format di risonanza internazionale!
Ma un secondo dopo, ho pensato:
sì, però io che racconto?
Sono una scienziata? No.
Sono un'artista? No.
Sono un'imprenditrice illuminata? No.
Sono, semplicemente una giornalista,
una giornalista del Tg1 e della Rai.
Però, poi ho pensato:
che strana la vita, eh!
Che caso, che bella coincidenza!
Essere coinvolta in un
evento di rilevanza mondiale
proprio a Fermo, dove tutto è partito.
Dove è partito tutto:
il mio sogno, le mie radici,
la mia famiglia,
a cominciare da un padre
che aveva tantissime passioni.
Faceva il geometra, di professione;
ma aveva tante passioni:
il teatro, la danza, lo sport,
e tra questi, anche la passione
del giornalismo.
Certo, per lui soltanto un hobby:
però davanti a me, nitida,
ho ancora l'immagine
di quella macchina da scrivere
posizionata in un angolo
della sala, su una scrivania antica,
e che con il suo ticchettio
è stata una compagna,
un'amica, forse una musa ispiratrice.
E allora ho pensato:
certo, in un mondo globalizzato,
dove tutti ci sentiamo davvero,
senza frontiere, cittadini del mondo,
basta un clic e siamo
dall'altra parte del pianeta,
io ho pensato che, invece,
la mia forza sono sempre
state proprio le mie radici,
il mio attaccamento proprio
a questo territorio, alla mia famiglia,
a quello che è stato il mio imprinting.
Ebbene, però, come vi dicevo all'inizio,
non è stata una favola,
il mio percorso non è stato semplice:
è stato tutto un percorso lento,
inesorabile, ma tutto in salita,
dove ogni tappa è stata
conquistata davvero con grande fatica,
centimetro per centimetro.
Lentezza, tradizione, gentilezza:
avevate mai pensato che questi tre fattori
potessero essere dei driver del successo?
Mi è capitato di leggere, poco tempo fa,
un libro di uno scrittore
che ho amato tantissimo,
Luis Sepúlveda,
e che purtroppo il Covid
ci ha portato via, l'anno scorso;
e questo libro ha un titolo
davvero particolare.
Eccolo qua: "Storia di una lumaca
che scoprì l'importanza della lentezza".
È la storia di una lumaca
che si chiama Ribelle,
e che si pone l'obiettivo
di compiere un viaggio davvero faticoso,
davvero ardito per lei che è una lumaca,
per raggiungere una destinazione
che per lei è la destinazione ideale.
In questo viaggio, coinvolge
addirittura anche altre lumache.
Poi, alla fine,
davvero quella destinazione
viene raggiunta,
davvero la meta è raggiunta;
e la lumaca si accorge
che quella che era forse
la sua vulnerabilità,
la sua lentezza rispetto ad altri animali
che invece erano più rapidi, più scaltri,
più veloci ad aggirare gli ostacoli,
a correre a raggiungere
i propri obiettivi,
ebbene no:
quella che era la sua vulnerabilità
invece diventa la sua forza.
Beh, allora io mi sono rivista -
vi verrà da sorridere,
ma io mi sono rivista in quella lumaca.
Passando al mondo dello sport,
posso dire che non sono
stata mai una velocista,
non sono stata mai una sprinter;
ma forse una maratoneta.
Insomma, non ho mai bruciato le tappe
perché ho scelto sempre un percorso
che rispettasse i miei valori
e i miei princìpi,
la mia tradizione, il mio imprinting.
Non ho bruciato le tappe:
però le ho individuate, memorizzate,
scalettate e alla fine raggiunte.
E allora, in un mondo, in una società
così, se vogliamo dire, di "fenomeni",
dove spesso vince chi zittisce l'altro,
chi è arrogante, chi ha la strafottenza,
io nel mio ambiente, che poi
gli ambienti di lavoro sono tutti uguali,
laddove c'è competizione,
c'è voglia di emergere,
c'è voglia di avere visibilità,
c'è voglia di raggiungere dei traguardi,
io ho fatto tutto un percorso
forse al contrario, alternativo.
Mantenendo la gentilezza,
mantenendo l'educazione,
mantenendo la fedeltà
e la coerenza ai miei valori.
Certo: tutto questo, forse,
a volte ha rallentato
il mio percorso professionale;
però l'ho raggiunto,
ho raggiunto quello che volevo fare.
E devo dire che è stato importante
che tutto sia partito davvero da qua,
perché qua si è fatta
la mia formazione culturale,
qui ho iniziato a collaborare
con i primi giornali,
con le emittenti private.
Insomma, con quella gavetta
che forse adesso non esiste più,
è un termine quasi anacronistico;
ma è stato un background
così forte, così prezioso
che mi ha permesso poi di arrivare in Rai.
All'inizio con i primi
contratti brevissimi;
poi contratti più lunghi,
e lunghi anni di precariato
fino alla stabilizzazione;
fino poi a condurre le edizioni
principali del telegiornale,
ad entrare stabile
nella redazione economica del Tg1
a condurre trasmissioni
importanti e di successo.
Mi è capitato di intervistare,
davvero, tantissimi personaggi:
ne voglio ricordare solo qualcuno.
Personaggi che non concedevano interviste,
personaggi che erano inavvicinabili,
che colleghe o colleghi
facevano di tutto per intervistare,
e magari non ci riuscivano.
Io voglio ricordare qualche nome:
Gorbaciov, Premio Nobel
per la Pace, il padre della perestroika.
Mi ricordo: l'ho incontrato
a Terni, era il 2001,
era venuto per ricevere un premio.
L'ho incontrato in questo salone,
e mi ricordo la sua autorevolezza
ma nello stesso tempo la sua
grande carica umana, umanitaria, forte.
Il suo sguardo pieno
di bontà, di sentimento.
Beh l'intervista
doveva durare cinque minuti.
Era stata una intervista concordata
con il suo staff: massimo cinque minuti.
Durò quasi mezz'ora,
perché si aprì così tanto
che mi raccontò il suo rapporto
con con la moglie,
che aveva perso da poco,
con la figlia.
Un altro esempio:
Zeffirelli, grande del cinema,
mi accolse nella sua villa
sull'Appia a Roma.
Aveva vicino un cagnolino:
un amore infinito,
una tenerezza infinita
per questo cagnolino
che l'ha tenuto sulle ginocchia
per tutta la durata dell'intervista
in questa casa meravigliosa,
dove ogni angolo era
bello, denso, pieno di ricordi,
di foto con le celebrities
più famose al mondo.
E anche lui, all'inizio,
era un po' schivo, non voleva parlare:
e poi dopo, alla fine,
mi promise che avrei fatto io
l'esclusiva per i suoi 80 anni,
per la festa dei suoi ottant'anni
al Teatro dell'Opera di Roma.
Un altro protagonista,
un altro campione dello sport
che ho avuto modo di intervistare
alla vigilia della partenza
del Giro d'Italia:
Marco Pantani.
Era il 2003: qualche mese dopo,
il14 febbraio 2004,
Marco ci avrebbe lasciato
in quella notte così tragica.
Questo ragazzo, così schivo, timido,
si aprì tantissimo
e addirittura mi raccontò
il suo amore per la musica.
E riuscì a intonare, anche,
un brano di una canzone preferita.
Beh, questo per dirvi:
come sono riuscita
ad ottenere questa intervista
e che altri magari non ci sono riusciti,
pur volendolo?
Sempre con il garbo, con la gentilezza,
entrando anche in punta di piedi
perché significa avere
il rispetto della vita degli altri.
Ed è lo stesso garbo,
lo stesso passo felpato
che ho oggi anche nel condurre
il telegiornale,
o una trasmissione come Unomattina.
E allora, io penso che davvero
c'è un modo alternativo che si può avere.
È quello della gentilezza,
che può essere davvero
una grande rivoluzione,
come dice Papa Francesco,
perché trasforma gli stili di vita,
modifica il rapporto con gli altri,
apre al dialogo e al confronto,
che per me che faccio
questo lavoro è fondamentale.
E allora, dico,
pensando magari ai giovani che sono qua
o che potranno ascoltare questo speech:
Veramente, c'è un modo
alternativo. Non siamo tutti omologati.
Anche se qualche volta
ho avuto così l'impressione, quasi,
di ammirare chi mi ha
sorpassato a destra e sinistra,
con l'arroganza,
con la strafottenza a pari merito,
quelli del "mors tua vita mea"
o di chi ha una visione
machiavellica della vita.
Però, ripeto, c'è un modo
alternativo, un percorso alternativo,
che è quello di rimanere
fedeli a se stessi,
fedeli anche ai propri valori.
Certo: questo può costare
un rallentamento,
a volte, nel proprio percorso.
Questa è la lentezza di cui io vi parlo.
Però, davvero: si può fare.
Mamma mia, sto parlando tantissimo.
Ho quasi parlato - 15 minuti, 14 minuti,
vedo il timer lì, implacabile.
No, è tantissimo per noi:
pensate che al telegiornale,
in questi 15 minuti,
vanno in onda 10, 11 servizi.
Uno dei miei pezzi,
fatti qualche settimana fa,
sul Recovery Plan,
durava un minuto e 15: erano 18 righe.
Quindi, davvero, ho parlato troppo
e sono riuscita solo a darvi
qualche pennellata
dell'affresco della mia vita.
Ma è importante:
non molliamo, non mollate.
Lo dico principalmente a me stessa,
perché davvero si può raggiungere
il proprio obiettivo, il proprio sogno,
rimanendo fedeli e coerenti a se stessi.
Io mi fermo qua.
Davvero spero di avervi passato,
di avervi trasmesso un'idea -
non lo so se bella o brutta -
ma un'idea che vi faccia volare,
che vi faccia raggiungere e concretizzare
i vostri sogni, i vostri progetti.
Davvero, ve lo auguro con tutto il cuore.
Mi fermo qua.
Grazie, veramente.
Le idee spiegano le ali.
Grazie.
(Applausi)